there are 600,000 people currently on
holiday worldwide with the company and
they're now looking for other ways to
get home all thomascook flights have
been immediately canceled putting about
20,000 jobs at risk the UK Civil
Aviation Authority says it will work
with the government to bring 150
thousand British travelers home over the
next fortnight the CIA is launching a
repatriation this is the largest
repatriation since the Second World War
and we will be bringing home everybody
back back to the UK as close as possible
to their return date this is a huge
operation 150,000 people currently
abroad we've chartered over 40 aircraft
and those aircraft are already in
position and in in the next few hours
we'll start bringing we'll start
bringing passengers home Kathryn Stancil
has more now Britain's oldest travel
company operating in more than a dozen
countries with 19 million customers a
year but Thomas Cook struggled to be
profitable despite a 1 billion dollar
injection of cash earlier this year the
company said on Friday it needed an
additional 250 million dollars to stave
off collapse bad news for the 600,000
people around the world on Thomas Cook
holidays when word spread about the dire
financial situation this hotel in
Tunisia briefly refused to let
holidaymakers leave demanding money
afraid that they wouldn't get paid if
the company went bankrupt
lucasz shisha PE I paid more than two
thousand dollars for the holiday they
want more than what I paid I told them
I'm not responsible for Thomas Cook
basically it's kind of blackmail if you
pay it you don't leave the British
government is promising to help anyone
stuck abroad I can reassure people that
in the worst-case scenario the
contingency planning is there to avoid
people being stranded more than 1
million people around the world have
holidays booked with Thomas Cook despite
going bust there's little danger they
will lose their money thanks to various
consumer protection schemes
Thomas Cook is seen as the inventor of
the modern
they package holiday a cabinetmaker from
Yorkshire he was a strong supporter of
the temperance movement and believed
travel would help Britain's refrain from
drinking alcohol he started out by
arranging day trips by train in the
1840s the excursions proved so popular
that within 20 years he was selling
tours to continental Europe the Middle
East and the United States but the
modern day company has been under
intense financial pressure rescued from
near bankruptcy eight years ago and how
people book their holidays has added to
the company's plight high street travel
shops have been facing stiff competition
from the internet and while package
holidays like those from Thomas Cook
often provide good value many consumers
are now shopping around online booking
their accommodation and flights
separately to create a bespoke travel
experience despite being a mainstay in
the British travel industry analysts say
the company struggled to compete
Thomas Cook is a marvelous brand it has
an incredible heritage but I'm afraid in
the 21st century in the ferocious
competition of the travel industry that
counts for nothing all that matters is
do you have a profitable business and
sadly in the case of Thomas Cook we know
the answer is no a 178 year old business
steeped in history but apparently
failing to keep up with modern times
catherine stancil al-jazeera
London well Francis Coppola is an
economist and joins us now from London
via Skype Frances thanks for joining us
we know of course that Thomas Cook's
experienced serious financial
difficulties over the last year but what
multiple factors have contributed to the
company's demise well the immediate
course appears to have been that they
needed some money to pay their debts and
the banks wouldn't cough up any more
their existing credit facilities were
fully drawn and they just couldn't
borrow any more they went to the UK
government to see the UK government
cough up some money in UK government
said no so that appears to being the
proximate reason for them failing
however they've gone into compulsory
liquidation which means that the company
is completely
basically saying it's a gun concern
which means that there's a much deeper
underlying insolvency and when you look
at the books you can see that really
what's happened is that they back in in
May they reported a loss of about 1.3
billion pounds so approximately 1.6
billion dollars I think arising from
having to write down the value of a
company and they'd bought in 2007 that
left them quite seriously insolvent
they've been trying to put together a
recapitalisation plan with their
creditors and with their owner Folsom
but obviously it looks like the last
minute the creditors have said no what
is it about the nature of the way people
travel these days the way they go online
to book their journeys now has Thomas
Cook been able to weather the storm to
adapt to changing times has that been a
factor in its demise as well I think
that's certainly been a factor they've
not really adapted to the modern trend
to book thing is online to mix and match
to book your your flight your hotels
your account you know your experiences
your trips all of it your cars all of it
separately what Thomas cook is still
offering he offering his packages it's
got these expensive high street shops
know who is it who goes into a high
street shop to book their holiday now
hardly anybody does so they've got that
as well they haven't really adapted to
changing taste changing trends changing
consumer behavior and that shows in
their profitability they haven't got any
profitable business lines really we saw
of course a few years ago the collapse
of monarch Airlines Thomas Cook now is a
major blow for internationally renowned
and respected brands what lessons are
there in this for other companies who
are watching on from the sidelines well
I think the lesson is that they've got
to be much quicker to realize what the
trends are in the industry and adapt to
them respond to them and make sure
they're ahead of the curve and also I
think a warning for all companies really
which is that don't set yourself with
huge amounts of debt
it's because that can come back and bite
you Francis Coppola in London thank you
very much pleasure